here's an example of a get ready for
grade level course in this case it's get
ready for sixth grade and there's a
couple of interesting things here first
of all you can see that the course is
broken down into units like all of our
courses are broken down and these units
are designed to match fairly closely to
the units in sixth grade so it can be
used in two different ways the get ready
for sixth grade course for example could
be used at the beginning of sixth grade
so that students can fill in all of the
gaps that they might have up to sixth
grade and then they could work on the
sixth grade course or it could be done
in parallel for example if in the sixth
grade course students are using are
working on the unit on ratios rates and
percentages then this unit right over
here in the get ready for sixth grade
can be used to make sure that students
have all the prerequisites for that
sixth grade unit
now what we recommend because most sixth
grade students will already have some of
the mastery we'll already know many of
the skills in the get ready for sixth
grade course we recommend that they
start with the course challenge by
taking a course challenge students are
going to have an opportunity to show
what they already know and also identify
what their existing gaps are if students
are doing well on the course challenge
they can keep taking it they're going to
get different exercises different items
every time and they can accelerate quite
quickly through the get ready for grade
level course but of course if they need
to fill in gaps they can then go to
those corresponding units so for example
i could go to this unit right over here
and do more focused skill based practice
on the things that they haven't mastered
yet and even within a unit you can also
use things like our unit tests which you
can see right over here to similar to a
course challenge accelerate through what
you already know but then also identify
the gaps for what you don't already know
so hopefully all of y'all enjoy using
the get ready for grade level courses i
just use sixth grade as an example it's
a way to ensure that students enter this
grade level enter whatever grade level
they are whatever course they are in
without those swiss cheese gaps there's
a way for them to fill them in and then
continue to proceed
at their own time and pace